we need to calculate nine point zero
zero five minus three point six or we
could view it as nine and five
thousandth minus three and six tenths
now whatever you do is subtracting
decimals problems the most important
thing and this is true when you're
adding decimals as well so you have to
line up the decimals so this is nine
nine point zero zero five minus three
point six minus three point six so we've
lined up the decimals and now we're
ready to subtract so now we can subtract
so we start up here we have five minus
nothing you can imagine this three point
six or this three and six ten so we
could add two zeros right here and it
would be the same thing as three and six
hundred thousands which is the same
thing as six tenths and when you look at
it that way it's a-okay five minus zero
is nothing and you just write a five
right there or you could have said that
nothing there would've been five -
nothing is five then you have 0 minus 0
which is just 0 and then you have a zero
minus 6 and you can't subtract 6 from
zero so we need to get something into
this space right here and what we need
essentially are going to do is regroup
we're going to take 1 1 from the 9 so
let's do that so let's take 1 1 from the
9 so it becomes an 8 and we need to do
something with that 1 1 we're gonna put
it in the tenths place now remember one
hole is equal to ten tenths this is the
tenths place so then this will become 10
you know sometimes it's taught that
you're borrowing the 1 but you're really
taking it and you're actually taking ten
from the place to your left
so one hole is ten tenths we're in the
tens place so you have 10 minus 6 let me
switch colors 10 minus 6 is 4
you have your decimal right there and
then you have 8 minus 3 is 5 so nine
point zero zero five minus 3.6 is five
point four zero five